[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه وهذه عناوينها
واشنطن سفينه روسيه عقب حادثه التصادم بين
مسيرتنا امريكيه ومقاتله روسيه موسكو
مسؤوليته
زعيمر يقول ان 70 الف جندي اوكراني
يقاتلون في بخموت لا يصاحب مهمه السيطره
عليها
حكومه باكستان تتوعد باعتقال عمران خان
والاخير يدعو انصاره لمواصله الكفاح ضدها
وشركه اوبن اي اي لذكاء الاصطناعي تطرح
نسخه جديده من روبوت تشات
اقرب الى مستوى البشر
[موسيقى]
في تطور اللافت يضيف بعدا جديدا للتصعيد
بين الطرفين اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه الاوروبيه انها اضطرت الى اسقاط
طائره مسيره من طراز ريفر كانت في مهمه
الروتينيه فوق البحر الاسود وقالت القياده
الامريكيه ان مقاتلات الروسيه نفذت
اعتراضا غير امن الامر الذي كاد ان يتسبب
في اسقاط مقاتله الروسيه والمسيره
الامريكيه مشيره الى انها اضطرت لاسقاط
المسيره تجنبا للحادث
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
في البيت الابيض جون كيربي قال ان الرئيس
صدام المقاتله الروسيه والمسيره الامريكيه
فوق البحر الاسود وفي فائده صحفيه اعتبر
ان اعتراض المقاتله الروسيه للمسيره كان
غير امن وغير احترافي مضيفا ان المسيره
الامريكيه لم تشكل اي تهديد وكانت تقوم
بمهمه في الاجواء الدوليه ووضح البيت
الابيض ان وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ستبلغ
المسؤولين الروس بمخاوف واشنطن بعد الحادث
كيرفي شدد على ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل
خدمه مصالحها الامنيه في البحر الاسود
اشيرت الى نواشنطن لا تحتاج الى تنسيق مع
روسيا عندما تقوم بالتحليق فوق هذه
المنطقه
وبعد ذلك اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن استدعاء السفير
الروسي في واشنطن انا تولي انتانوف بعد
هذه الحادثه رئيس اشار ايضا الى ان السفير
الامريكي في روسيا نقل رساله قويه على حد
وصفه الى وزاره الخارجيه الرسل
اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فنفت روايه
البنتاغون بشار حادثه اسقاط طائره مسيره
ملكيه فوق البحر الاسود وقالت الدفاع
الروسيه ان المسيره الامريكيه اقتربت من
المجال الجوي الروسي فوق شبه جزيره القرم
حسب بيانها واضافه المسيره الامريكيه
اغلقت اجهزه تعريفها فانطلقت مقاتله
الروسيه كانت مهمه في المنطقه الى موقع
المسيره الدفاع الروسيه لفت ايضا ان تكون
مقاتلاتها استخدمت الذخيره ضد المسيره
الامريكيه او قامت حتى بالاقتراب منها
بشكل خطير مؤشره الى ان المسيره قامت
بمناوره حاده تسببت في خسارتها لارتفاعها
وفقدانها السيطره لينتهي بها الامر
بالارتطاب بسطح البحر
في المقابل المتحدث باسم البنتاجون باترك
رايدر اكد انه لن يفصح عن تفاصيل المعدات
والمهمه التي كانت تقوم بها المسيره
الامريكيه في البحر الاسود واوضح ان روسيا
لم تعثر على المسيره بعد سقوطها
لن اخوض في تفاصيل المعدات التي كانت على
متن الطائره المسيره كانت وحده مراقبه
وبسبب الضرر كنا في موقف دفعنا لتحطيمها
في البحر الاسود على حد علمي الروس لم
يستعيدوا هذه الطائره وعن جهود استعادتنا
لا توجد معلومات حتى الان ونقيم الموارد
التي لدينا في هذه المنطقه
ينضموا الينا من واشنطن الزميل فيرغانم هل
هناك من تفاصيل اضافيه بشهر حادثه البحر
الاسود
الامريكيون التزموا الى حد كبير
جدا بيان الاول وقالوا الروس هم الذين
لاحقوا هذه المسيره في الاجواء الدوليه
فوق المياه الدوليه
ووصفوا ما ذكرته انت قبل لحظات محمد حول
تفاصيل ما حدث من ان طائرتين روسيتين اولا
القتاء نوع من الوقود على هذه المسيره لم
تقع ثم اقتربت منها احدى المقاتلات
الروسيات وتسببت بضرر في مروحيه هذه
المسيره الامريكيه والامريكيون هم الذين
تسببوا بسقوطها الى المياه الامريكيون الى
حد كبير جدا يريدون الابتعاد عن الكلام
الكبير يريدون ايضا ان يحولوا هذا الحادث
العسكري الى قضيه دبلوماسيه لذلك تهتم
بذلك الان وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
بالتحدث الى الروس طيب ولكن هل هناك
معلومات او تاكيدات بشان مصير المقاتله
الروسيه هناك تحدثت في البدايه عن سقوط
مقاتله روس يه ايضا الاصطدامها بالمصيره
الامريكيه التي قال البنتاجون بانه اسقطها
تجنبا لوقوع حادث من هذا النوع
قبل قليل انه بعد ان تسبب الروس بالضرر في
المسيره الامريكيه عادت الطائرات الروسيه
الى مكان انطلاقها وبالتالي من المؤكد
اقله بالنسبه للامريكيين ان الطائرات
الروسيه والطياريين الروس عادوا سالمين
الى قواعدهم هناك ايضا محاولات لتحويل هذه
الازمه التي كانت في الاجواء الى الى ازمه
دبلوماسيه ولكن هل هناك حتى الان اي
محاولات لنزع فتيل الازمه واشنطن تتحدث عن
استدعاء سفير الروسي تتحدث عن ايصال سفير
الامريكي رساله قويه الى موسكو وفي هذا
الوقت الذي تم فيه
روسيا كامل الروايه الامريكيه
تعمد المتحدثون الامريكيون اكان جون كربي
عندما تحدث الى الصحفيين في ظهر هذا اليوم
بتوقيت العاصمه واشنطن او كان المتحدث
باسم البنترنت عن مدى الى حد كبير جدا ان
يستعملوا لغه بارده ليس فيها اي نوع من
التصعيد يتحدث فقط
الامريكيون عن ان ما حدث حدث في الاجواء
الدوليه وان التصرفات الروسيه كانت غير
مهنيه لم يستعملوا اي كلام اخر وابتعدوا
تماما عن كلمه تصعيد فهم من الواضح انهم
ليسوا في ازمه ولا يريدون اثاره ازمه مع
روسيا او اي تصعيد مع روسيا شكرا وسنتابع
معك المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه الحادثه
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر تطورات معركه بخموت كشق كشف قائد
مجموعه فاجنر ياباني
وجود حوالي 70 الف جندي اوكراني في مخبوط
ومحيطها قال بروكين ان قوات تستعد للهجوم
المضاد في محمود وتسعى لعزل قواتنا كما
اضاف قائد مجموعه باجنر ان المعارك تزداد
حده كلما اقترب مقاتله من وسط المدينه كما
اوضح ان قوته تواجه مقاومه شرسه وان الوضع
في بخموت صعب للغايه
[موسيقى]
روسيا لا تزال تواصل سعيها للسيطره على
مدينه بخموت الواقعه بدومباس شرق اوكرانيا
فماذا تعني سيطره الروس فعلا على بخموت
وهل هناك اي امتيازات استراتيجيه موسكو
تقول اذا سيطره على مخموت ستحدث ثغره في
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه وبالتالي السيطره
الكامله على منطقه زومباس الصناعيه وهي
هدف كبير في الحرب حسب رويترز فاذا سقطت
مخباط هناك ثلاث طرق صعبه فقط يمكن للروس
من خلالها الوصول الى كراماتورسك الجائزه
الاستراتيجيه
وفقا للتايم ويعتقد الخبراء انه حتى لو
تمكنت قوات فاجنر من اختراق مخموت وقد
كسبت اوكرانيا وقتا كافيه لجعل الطريق الى
كروماتورس غير سالك امام الروس وفق
المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه
تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست قال ان القوه
العسكريه لاوكرانيا متداوره بعد عام من
الحرب اذ تدور الشكوك حول قدرتكيف على شان
هجوم في الرابع المقبل
بين هذه الخطوط والعاصمه كييف يدور شك في
قدره الاخيره على شن هجوم مضاد في الربيع
كما قالت وتتحضر
فعام من الحرب انهت جيشها وافقده الافا من
ذوي الخبره القتاليه
في احدث التقارير الغربيه فان حاله القوه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه متدهوره بسبب حجم
الاصابات التي اخرجت العديد من المقاتلين
الاكثر خبره من ساحه المعركه
يرجع مسؤولون اوروبيون وامريكيون حاله
التدهور هذه لعده اسباب
فخلال عام وقع 120 الف جندي اوكراني بين
قتيل وجريح جلهم من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
حجم الخساره هذا دفع كييف للدفع بمجندين
عديم الخبره لسد النقص على خطوط القتال
اضافه للنقص الاساسي في الذخيره
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست فان الاشهر
القادمه تشكل تحديا امام كييف لاستعاده
زمام المبادره وشن هجوم في هذا الوضع الذي
يعاني فيه جيشها من نقص في العدد والعتاد
بالمقابل فان حال الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حال وان كان عدده يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف جيش
اوكرانيا
فوافقا للتقديرات الغربيه ذاتها فقد خسرت
موسكو قرابه 200 الف جندي بين قتيل وجريح
اضافه لمشاكل في الذخيره والقوى العامله
وما بين تشكيك بقدره كييف وموسكو على
الهجوم والدفاع فان التقديرات تقول ان
عاما من الحرب انهك الجيشين وان عاما
جديدا بدا لتوهه ايضا بالحديد والنار
[موسيقى]
رئيس الامريكي سابق دول ترامب يلوح مره
اخرى بقدرته على انهاء الحرف اوكرانيا في
حملات الانتخابيه المبكره ترامب دعا من
جديد الى سلام تفاوضي من قبل اوكرانيا
بواسطه الولايات المتحده كما شدد على
ضروره انهاء الصراع فورا والجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات ايضا ببساطه امريكيه
ترامب الذي ادلى بهذه التصريحات خلال
برنامج تلفزيوني على قناه فوكس نيوز نفى
الحاجه الى تغيير النظام في روسيا مؤكدا
في المقابل على ضروره تغيير نظام جو بايدن
لايصاله الولايات المتحده الى الفوضى على
حد
ركز بشكل كبير على الحرب في اوكرانيا
معتبرا ان الازمه العالميه الحاليه نجمت
بالاساس على خلفيه الحرب المتواصله في
اوكرانيا التي لم تتمكن اداره بايدن من
منعها وقال ترامب ان روسيا لم تكن لتهاجم
اوكرانيا ابدا لو كان هو رئيسا كما دعى
الرئيس الامريكي السابق الى سلام تفاوضي
ببساطه امريكيه حيث اعتبر ان كلا الجانبان
او الجانبين مرهقان الان
ومستعدان لعقد صفقه وقال ترامب انه من
الواجب بدء الاجتماعات على الفور لانهاء
هذه الحرب وعدم تضيع الوقت
[موسيقى]
الاتهامات المتبادله بين المعسكر الغربي
وروسيا تتصاعد بشكل متواصل هذه المره جاءت
دور على وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الذي اتهم
الغرب بمعاداه روسيا وشيطانتها
قال ان هناك كراهيه فظيعه لروسيا في الدول
الغربيه التي لا تتوقف عن التهديد
بالاصطدام المباشر مع موسكو واتهم لابروف
تحديدا الولايات المتحده واستراليا
وبريطانيا بتدبير مواجهه تستمر لسنوات في
اسيا عبر اطلاقها تحالف اوكس بشان
الغواصات
العالم يبني تكتلات مثل اوكوس ويطور البنى
التحتيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا و
يراهن بجديه على مواجهه تستمر لسنوات
طويله الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي لاخضاع
دول اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان يتوقف
وهنا كشفت الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده واستراليا
تهدف الى انشاء اسطول جديد من الغواصات
التي تعمل بطاقه نوويه بغيه مواجهه نفوذ
الصين المتزايد في منطقه المحيطين الهند
والهادئ كما ترى ردود فعل حاده من الحلفين
الحليفين او الحلفين الاستراتيجيين روسيا
وصيد على هذا الاتفاق
المواجهه لن تكون ثنائيه بين واشنطن وبكين
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وانما
متعدده الاقطاب هذا هو الحال الذي فرضته
اتفاقيه شراء استراليا لغواصات هجوميه
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه بموافقه امريكيه
بريطانيه تحت ما يعرف باتفاقيه اوكوس ما
يضع الصين امام اكثر من خصم وقوه فالصفقه
التي ستبلغ تكلفتها نحو 245 مليار دولار
وستنفذ على مدار العقود الثلاثه المقبله
هدفها القريب هو بناء قوه بحريه ثابته
لمواجهه توسع النفوذ بكين في المنطقه اما
الهدف الابعد فهو جعل واشنطن قادره على
الاستفاده من حلفائها في مواجهه الصين دون
ان تكون وحيده امام قوه بكين البحريه
وزير دفاع استراليا
اكد ان الصفقه الغواصات النوويه كانت
ضروريه لامن بلاده في وقت تشهد منطقه
المحيط الهادئ اكبر حشد عسكري تقليدي في
المنطقه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
نشاهد النظام العالمي القائمه على القواعد
يتعرض لضغط هائل في اوروبا الشرقيه وفي
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ونحن نشهد اكبر
حشد عسكري تقليدي شهدناه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهذا يحدث داخل منطقتنا
وعلينا الرد على ذلك
اما الصين وبلهجه شديده ادانت معتبرته
الطريق الخاطئه والخطر الذي تسلكه الشراكه
المبرمه بين الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا ضمن برنامج الغواصات
الصين تشدد على ان اتفاق اوكسو بين امريكا
واستراليا وبريطانيا سيقود نظام عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ونعبر عن اعتراضنا
الشديد عليه لانه يبين ان هذه الدول
الثلاث تغاضت عن القلق الذي عبرنا عنه
واختارت الطريق الخطا
موقف روسيا لا يقل حده عن حليفتها
الاستراتيجيه اذ اتهمت اطراف الاتفاقيه
بتدبير مواجهه تستمر لسنوات في اسيا
العالم يبني تكتلات مثل اوكوس ويطور البنى
التحتيه بحلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا و
يراهن بجديه على مواجهه تستمر لسنوات
طويله الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي لاخضاع
دول اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان يتوقف
اتفاق ثلاثي تقابله معارضه من روسيا
والصين وسيجبر الاخيره على التفكير اكثر
من مره قبل الاقدام على اي مواجهه تدور
حول تايوان او غيرها لان الخصم لم يعد
واحدا وانما ثلاثه ولكل منهم قوته الضاربه
[موسيقى]
يمكن تفسير موقف موسكو بخصوص تمديد
الاتفاقيه برغبتها في الضغط من اجل رفع
العقوبات المفروضه على صادراتها ولو جزئيا
المحت اليه في وقت سابق
تتابعون ايضا في اخبار الساعه
انهيار سيليكون فادي وسكنتشر يضع
الفيدراليه الامريكي امام خيارات قاسيه
بشان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الساعه قال وزير
الداخليه الباكستانيه رانا ثناء الله ان
شرطه ستعتقل رئيس الوزراء خان اليوم
وستقدمه للمحاكمه تاتي تصريحات وزير
الداخليه الباكستاني بالتزامن مع اشتباكات
بين الشرطه وانصاري عمران خان خارج منزله
في مدينه لاهور صدرت اوامر لخانه بالموتور
امام قاضي في اسلام اباد يوم الجمعه للرد
على اتهامات بيع هدايا حكوميه بشكل غير
قانوني تلقاها خلال فتره رئاسته للوزراء
واخفاء عدد من الاصول
بالمقابل وصف عمران خان الحكومه
الباكستانيه بحكومه اللصوص داعيه انصاره
الى مواصله الكفاح اذا ما تم قتله او سجله
انا احارب معركتكم لقد حاربت طوال حياتي
وساواصل ذلك لكن اذا حدث لي شيء ما ودخلت
السجن او قتلت فعليكم اثبات ان هذه الامه
ستستمر في كفاحها بدون عمران خالد فهذه
حكومه لصوص ويجب ان لا تقبلوا بذلك ابدا
[تصفيق]
وفي تصريحات للعربيه كذا مستشار عمران
اتهامات ضد خانه اساس لها معبره عن ثقته
وامله بالقضاء الباكستاني بقبول الكفاله
مقابل حريه رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق
عمران خان متهم باخذ هديه منحت له من قبل
احد الضيوف خلال زيارته وهناك مكان مخصص
لايداع هذه الهدايا فالشخص الذي تقدم له
يمكنه دفع مبلغ محدد واخذها قانونيا لكن
اليوم يتهمون عمران خان ببيعها فلا يوجد
اي اساس لهذه التهمه المحكمه قالت انه
يعجب المثول امامها في الثامن عشر من
الشهر الجاري اي بعد اربعه ايام من اليوم
فما الغرض من انتقاله اليوم نحن نشعر ان
هناك دوافع ونوايا خبيثه ويريدون التخلص
منه نهائيا لانهم لا يمكنهم ان ينافسوه في
الانتخابات
مع زميل عبد الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن هل
تم اعتقال خان كما وعد وزير الداخليه
نعم بناء على تصريحات وزير الداخليه
الباكستاني رنا سناء الله فقد مضت المهله
التي قالب انه سوف يتم اعتقاله وانقضى يوم
الثلاثاء وبدانا بيوم جديد نحن الان في
باكستان التوقيت هنا هي ساعات الصباح
الاولى من يوم الاربعاء ولم تتمكن الشرطه
الباكستانيه من اعتقال رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان للمره الثانيه
الان الاوضاع بدات تعود الى طبيعتها في
عدد من المدن الباكستانيه باستثناء مدينه
لاهور هناك حاله من الترقب
الحذر ان صح ان نقول
الشرطه انسحبت من محيط مقر اقامه رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان وتم استبدالها
او تعزيزها بقوات من القوات شبه النظاميه
او القوات الدرك الان هناك العشرات من
انصاب رئيس الوز السابق يتوافدون على الحي
الذي يقيم فيه رئيس وزراء السابق وباتوا
انجاز ان نقول يسيطرون على مداخل هذا الحي
كان هناك اشتباك طفيف بين عدد من المحتجين
والقوات شبه النظاميه التي جاءت الى
المنطقه الساعات ربما المقبله ستكون حاسمه
لتقرير ما ان كان رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان سيرضخ لقرار المحكمه وسيمثل
امامها في التاريخ المقرر الثامن عشر من
الشهر المقبل اما ان انصاره سوف يحاولون
او سيمنعون قوات الامن من اعتقاله
اضافه الى هنا اود ان اشير بان اليوم من
المقرر ان تستمع
محكمه استنابات العليا لطلب تقدم به
الفريق القانوني لعمران خان
لايقاف العمل بمذكره الاعتقال الصادره
بحقه
لسيما في مابات يعرف به قضيه الهدايا ولكن
هل من الخيارات المتاحه امام رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه سابق تسليم نفسه مباشره الى
المحكمه
دون اعتقاله من قبل الشرطه
من المفترض ان يتسلم رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان مذكره
الاعتقال بحقه وكان من المفترض ان يتم
نقله
بمروحيه خاصه الى العاصمه اسلام اباد لكن
حتى حتى الان لا يزال رئيس الوزراء السابق
يرفض الامتثال
لتوجيهات الشرطه وانصاره حال دون اصول
فريق شرطه السنابات الى مقر
اقامته
الفريق القانوني العمران خان يقول بانه
كان من المفترض ان تنتظر الشرطه الى يوم
السبت المقبل بدل ان تقوم بهذه
الحمله او هذه العمليه لاعتقاله والتي
اثارت انصاره
هناك تخوف حقيقه في الشارع ولاسيما بين
مؤيدين رئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان لن
يتم وهذا يمهد ربما لاطاله امد اعتقاله
وتوجيه مزيد من الاتهامات ضده
وتعتبر ان ما تقوم به الشرطه هو بتوجيهات
من الحكومه لايجاد حاله من عدم الاستقرار
لتاجيل موعد الانتخابات
المقرره في اقليم البنجاب في تاريخ
الثلاثين من شهر ابريل المقبل عبد الرحمن
شكرا لك وسنتابع معك اخر التفاصيل بشان
ازمه دخان
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده انهيار مصرفي سيليكون
فاليتشر قد يفرض قرارات جديده على
الاحتياطي الفيدراليه الامريكي فبعد ان
كان يعتزم رفع اسعار الفائده توقع
التقارير صحفيه ان يتخلل فيدراليه عن خطته
خلال شهر مارس على ان يعيد العمل بها
لاحقا صحيفه
ذكرت انه لم يعد من المتوقع زياده اسعار
الفائده خلال اجتماع مجلس الاحتياطي
المقبل
وابدت توابع انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
لاستمرار خسائر اسهل اسهم البنوك العالميه
رغم تاكيدات الرئيس الامريكي القدره على
تهدئه تلك الاسواق
خسائر بالجمله اذا تكبدت البنوك العالميه
فوفقا بلومبرج فقد خسرت الاسهم الماليه
العالميه
465 مليار دولار من قبلتها السوقيه في
يومين في اعقاب انهيار بنك سيليكون
وكانت البروكولا الامريكيه الاكثر تضرا
كما ان اسهم بنوك وشركات التامين
الاوروبيه انخفضت بدورها
مصرف سيليكون فالي اكبر مصرف يتعرض
للانهيار منذ الازمه الماليه العالميه عام
2008 كما ثار مخاوف من حدوث ازمه النصرفيه
جديده في جميع انحاء العالم وتعود اسباب
هير البنك الى فشله في التعامل مع عمليه
سحب الهائله لموضيعي فضلا عن قرارات زياده
اسعار الفائده التي تم اتخاذها في الاساس
لمكافحه التضخم
معنا من الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعات كارديف
مترو اهلا بك دكتور هل نحن امام ازمه
ماليه عالميه كالذي حدث في 2008
طبعا هي اكيد ازمه حاده واعتقد ان
الاقتصاد الامريكي ليست هي الازمه الوحيده
هي ازمه العقار كانت
بعد ازمه العقار وطريقه التعاطي بها وايضا
ازمه كورونا وطريقه التعاطي بها هي ازمه
عالميه اعتقد ان حتى بقصد او بدون قصد تم
تصدير الازمه الامريكيه والامريكان انا
اعتبرهم دائما اساتذه في خلق الازمات وفي
تصدير ازماتهم الى الدول الاخرى وخاصه الى
حلفاء فبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه الازمه تعتبر
انا بعتبرها من الادارات او الحالات
الاخيره
للاقتصاد الامريكي لانه عالم الازمات حاده
من مديونيه تتجاوز 30 تريليون اعتقد سيضاف
الى هذه الازمه ما يزيد على عشره تريليون
جديده لضخ اموال او اوراق ماليه في
الاسواق
والان ليس فقط كما في تقريركم ان الاسهم
البنوك هبطت وانما توجد حتى صناديق تامين
اوروبيه او دعت اموالها في البنوك
الامريكيه تعاني الان من فقدان جزء كبير
منها كما حاله السويد التي قام ستخسر او
خسرت اوريدي تقريبا مليار يورو في من خلال
هذا البنك طيب لكن الحكومه الامريكيه وعدت
بانها لن تتدخل لانقاذ اي بنك بما فيها
البنك الذي تعرض لهذه الازمه هل احجام
الولايات المتحده واحجام واشنطن عن التدخل
المباشر لضخ استثمارات او مساعدات جديده
لتلك البنوك قد يفاقمن هذه الازمه
طبعا لانه حتى هي لو قامت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لتفادي اي نوع من هبه
اجتماعيه وتظاهرات او ازمات داخليه
اجتماعيه بتعويض المواطنين رغم انهم ليس
كما تقول اداره بايدن
الحكومه الامريكيه تضمن فقط 250 الف دولار
من لكل الوداع الذي لديه على سبيل المثال
مليون دولار سيحصل فقط على 250 مليون الف
دولار فبالتالي لا اعتقد انها ستعوض
المواطنين بكل المبالغ على الاقل سندات
الدوله والخزينه ستتم الاجاز عليها كما
حدث في اوروبا حيث خسر الذي المالكين لتلك
السندات تقريبا 70% من منها واما بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الاجانب
كما يقول مثل البناء لعبته وخسرت كما هي
حاله الصناديق التامينيه
واعتقد ان الاورده الازمه في المعسكر
الاوروبي
موجوده الان بانخفاض خلال انخفاض
الاسهم وانخفاض البورصه وايضا صناديق
التامين التي اودعت مئات المليارات في
البنوك الامريكيه الاحتياطي كان عنده توجه
لرفع الفائده من اجل مواجهه التضخم هل هذه
المحاولات جاءت بنتائج عكسيه ومحاولات
الان لوقف رفع اسعار الفائده هل ستساهم في
تخفيف حده هذه الازمه
يعني حين تقوم باكشن او بتصرف معين او
اجراء معين كما كلمات اقتصاديه اجراء معين
ويفشل وتعمل نفس الاجراء ويفشله وتعمل نفس
الاجراء ويبشر اذا لماذا تستمر في هذا
الاتجاه السؤال البسيط كل البنوك المركزيه
حتى في دول العالم الثالث تراقب نشاط
البنوك الخاصه والعامه بشكل دوري ويومي
ولديها اكسس او اتصال في البيانات اليوميه
للمدعين
الضرائبيه ولقضايا الفوائد فلماذا سكتت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على هذا البنك
الم تكن تعلم بذلك يعني حتى كان لصالح
الاقتصادي الامريكي ان يكون حتى افلاس
البنك افلاس ضمن اطار موجه كما حدثت افلاس
اليونان في فرحه مرحله ما كان هناك افلاس
ولكن تحت الاداره والسيطره فبالتالي لم
تكن له تداعيات اجتماعيه وسياسيه كبيره
فبالتالي كان ممكن تتدارك اذا هذا الموضوع
الا اذا كان هناك نقول فساد اداري وضعف
الرقابه وانا لا اعتقد انها كان هناك سعي
لتصدير الازمه خارج الولايات المتحده
في نهايه هذه المقابله دكتور عبد اللطيف
درويش شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
تابعون ايضا في اخبار الساعه
ترامب يهاجم مجددا ويقول انا صرعتك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الساعه ادلى
مايكل كفن محامي
السابق الذي تحول الى
احدائه ادلى بافادته الاثنين امام هيئه
محل كبرى في نيويورك في اطار تحقيق حول
قضيه حساسه قد تكون الاقرب لاسقاط الترب
قد تكون هذه المراه شوكه في انتخابات لن
تكتب النصر للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في السباق الرئاسي لعام 2004
القضيه الاقرب لاسقاطه هكذا تصنف اذا ما
وجهت التهمه الجنائيه الى الترامب حول دفع
محاميه السابق مايكل كوهن 130 الف دولار
للممثله ستورمي دانييلز ليشتري صمتها قبل
اسبوعين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز
فيها المرشح الجمهوري على الديمقراطيه
هيلر كلينتون
ادعاءات خرجت للعلن منذ خمس سنوات ولكنها
اليوم تقترب الى حافه المحاكم مع ادلاء
كوهن الذي استحال الى احد الد اعداء ترامب
بافادته امام هيئه محلفين كبرى في نيويورك
في اطار تحقيق حول القضيه ليؤكد انه ليس
انتقاما وانما يقدم الحقيقه
فبعد سجنه لثلاث سنوات اوضح ماليا انه
تصرف باعاز صريح من ترامب الذي اعاد له
المبلغ فور دخوله المكتبه البيضاوي
النيابه العامه في منهات بدورها استدعت
ايضا ترامب للادلاء بافادته بحسب صحف
امريكيه ما يعني ان توجيها الاتهام الى
الرئيس السابق قد يكون وشيكا
حمله سياسيه شعواء تهدف الى النيل من
المرشح الذي يتقدم باشواط هكذا يصف ترامب
تلك المزاعم حتى حينما ظهرت لاول مره
نفاها مرارا وتكرارا خلال احدى رحلاته
الجويه
وذكرت نيويورك تايمز ان التهمه التي قد
توجه الى ترامب هي القيام بتصريحات حسابيه
خاطئه لاخفاء انتهاك لقواعد تمويل الحمله
الانتخابيه لتصبح عودته الى البيت الابيض
شبه مستحيله في العام القادم
[موسيقى]
لا يستثني احدا من الهجوم اللاداحين يتعلق
الامر بالمنافسه على الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله هجمات ترامب استهدفت مره
اخرى حاكمه فلوريدا
صديقه السابق الذي اوصفه من جديد بغير
المخلص رئيس الجمهوريه السابق عاد ليعبد
فضائله على ديسانتس حيث قال ان الحياه
السياسيه لحاكم فلوريدا كانت ستنتهي لو لم
يؤيد حملته التي نجحت عام 2018
وتنح في الافق منافسه سياسيه شرسه بين
ترامبس حيث تجير العديد من الاستطلاعات
الى ان حاكم فلوريدا سيكون المنافس الاقوى
لترامب على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
وعلى الطرف الاخر فان ديسان لم يبادر الى
التعليق على الهجمات المتكرره فالمتحدث
باسم رفض بشكل صريح التعليق على تصريحات
ترامب كما انفسه كان تفادي التعليق او
تفادى التعليق على تصريحات الرئيس السابق
واكتفى بالقول انه لا يقضي وقته في محاوله
تشويه سمعه الجمهوريين الاخر
[موسيقى]
منظمه الصحه العالميه بان هجره العاملين
في قطاع رعايه الصحيه من الدول الاكثر
فقرا تتزايد الى الدول الغنيه التي تسعى
بدورها الى تعويض خساره الاطقم العامله
بها جراء كورونا المنظمه اضافه حركه
الهجره هذه كانت موجوده قبل ازمه كورونا
لكنها تزايدت في ظل احتدام المنافسه
العالميه وقال مدير المنظمه ان 55 دوله
بها بعض المنظومات الصحيه الاكثر هشاشه
على مستوى العالم تعاني من نقص الموظفي
الرعايه الصحيه
تقدم توم توجيهات وزير الامن البريطاني
بطلب الى المركز البريطاني للامن
السيبراني للنظر في مدى الحاجه الى حظر
تطبيق تيك توك الصيني تيك توك الصيني من
الهواتف الحكوميه ودعا الوزير البريطاني
الى ضروره فهم التهديدات التي يمثلها هذا
التطبيق قبل اتخاذ اي قرار بخصوص الموضوع
ونفى ذات المتحدث اتخاذ اي قرار بهذا
الخصوص مؤكدا ان الموضوع لا يزال قائد
الدراسه من طرف الجهه المختصه ولم يستبعد
وزير الامن البريطاني ان تحذوا بلاده حذو
حكومات اخرى في حظر التطبيق لكنه اكد ان
اي خطوه ستتم بعد الاطلاع على تقرير
المركز الامن السيبرانين
نقلت صحيفه جلوبال تايمز الصينيه عن خبير
يعمل بوزاره الموارد البشريه الصينيه ان
الصين تخطط لرفع سن التقاعد بشكل تدريجي
وعلى مراحل للتعامل مع زياده اعداد او
اعداد كبار السن في البلاد
للتعامل مع زياده اعداد كبار السن الصين
تخطط لرفع سن التقاعد سيكون الرفع على
مراحل وبشكل تدريجي وسائل اعلام صينيه
اكدت ان من قارب سن التقاعد سيكون عليه
تاجيله والميزه هي السماح للافراد باختيار
موعد التقاعد بناء على ظروف الشخص الاتجاه
لرفع سن التقاعد ياتي بعد تراجع عدد
السكان وتقدم الاعمار ما يسبب الضغط على
ميزانيات المعاشات خصوصا بعد التوقعات
بتضاعف اعداد من هم اكثر من 60 عاما بحلول
الفين وخمسه وثلاثين
نختم بصوره نادره نشرتها وكاله ناسا
للفضاء التقطها تلسكوب لنجم على عتاب
الموت بعد ظهور الاشعه الحمراء من حولك
واشارت ناسا الى ان النجم الذي رصده
تلسكوبها كان مسافرا عبر الفضاء منذ نحو
خمسه عشر الف سنه كما يبعد ايضا حوالي 15
الف سنه ضوئيه
[موسيقى]
في النهايه هذا تذكير بابرز العناو
واشنطن تستدعي سفير الوصيه عاقبه حادثه
التصادم بين مسيره الامريكيه ومقاتله
الروسيه وموسكو
ما يصاحب مهمه السيطره عليه
حكومه باكستان تتوعد باعتقال عمران خام
والاخير يدعو انصاره لمواصله الكفاح ضد
الحكم
وشركه اوبن اي اي للذكاء الاصطناعي تطرح
نسخه جديده من روبوت تشيك تشاد اقرب الى
مستوى البشر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]